i think today
you're i've looked at the best mentors
because today because of the web you can
follow someone you don't even know you
can link read what they write you can
read their blogs you can interact in
ways with them sometimes you can talk to
them they'll talk back on social media
so we have more choices today on that
than ever but i also try to find don't
have the belief that your mentor has to
be perfect because none of us are
there's no perfect human beings and even
if you are perfect someone else will
turn around saying you're not perfect
from their perspective so what you
really want to do is just say let me
find two or three people that have
answers that have proven it by their
life example not because they can
verbalize it how people's lips move
don't matter how do their feet move for
10 or 20 years and so i've always looked
for people that were not only successful
in the exterior world but they're really
happy and that they're contributing to
society in a meaningful way because
those are the people that are most
fulfilled and so i think today you have
to get clear what do you want and then
go looking and it's not hard to look
again because of the world we live in
today